This is Foundations
of Osteopathic
Medicine lecture
on head and neck
embryology, given
by Dr. Aki Watanabe.
Just like my
previous lecture on
introduction to
the head and neck,
the same rules
apply for my slides.
So any red text on
slides mean that
they're fair game
for the exam,
as well as anatomical
structures that are
labeled either in red
or in red highlight.
and make sure to
pay attention to
any of the
clinical correlates
that I go over
during my lectures.
And finally, I highly
recommend going over
the learning objectives
that I list in the
course preparation
guide for this lecture,
which will give you the
topics you should focus
on when studying for
the lecture content.
So here's a video
showing the remarkable
changes that happen
in the head and
neck during development.
So this is about
a 30-second clip that
goes to the journey
of four to five
-week-old embryo to
14 weeks. So this is
showing the changes
that's happening in
the head and neck
during essentially
the first trimester.
So during the lecture,
we'll be talking
about some of the
processes that are
involved in this
incredible transformation.
So in the first part
of this lecture,
we'll talk about the
segmented structures
in the head and
neck. And then in the
second part, we'll
talk about the rebels
that go against these
segmented regions.
And then the third
and the last part,
we'll talk about the
germ layer contributions
to the head and
neck structures.
So these include
the ectoderm,
endoderm, mesoderm,
and neurocrestal
derivatives that
exist in the head.
So let's start talking
about segmented
structures.
And so if you
look at somebody's
head or face, it's
hard to figure
out any segmented
structures.
But if you look at
the postcranium,
you do see some segmented
structures, as you
talked about probably
in previous
embryology lectures.
For example, when
you pay attention to
the vertebrae and the
ribs, you can clearly
see segmented
structures and system of
organization that
happens in the body.
So what about the head?
Well, in order to
look at segments
that occur in
the head, we need
to pay attention
to early embryos.
So when you look at
the top row, which
shows embryos around
four to five weeks
across different
animals, do you see any
segmented structures
around the head?
Here they are. And
you might have seen
these knobs that are
coming off of the neck
of the embryo. So
there are four to six
pharyngeal arches that
exist in early embryos
of different animals.
In humans, there
are four that are very
visible but they're
actually six pharyngeal
arches in the
beginning but we understand
a little bit about
the fifth arch which
tends to disappear
and then the fourth is
very closely related
to six so you can
consider them four and
six arches to be together
so in total there
are four visible
pharyngeal arches on the
external surface of
the embryo and these
are called pharyngeal
or brachial arches.
Here at the center
of the slide,
you see a cross-sectional
image of an embryo,
which is cut
basically where the
blue line is on this
top right inset
image. And so we're
looking down from the
top of this embryo.
And you'll notice
that pharyngeal
arches are just
part of this
larger pharyngeal
apparatus.
So arches are
the evaginated
segments of the ectoderm.
And there are pharyngeal
clefts that represent
the invagination of
the ectoderm, and
they exist between two
adjacent pharyngeal
arches. Similarly,
there's the pharyngeal
pouch, which is the
invagination of the endoderm
that's within the
embryo. And then between
the cleft and the
pouch is the pharyngeal
membrane. And these
are numbered from
cranial to caudal
direction. So the first arch
will have pharyngeal
arch one, and then
posterior to that will
be the pharyngeal cleft
one and pharyngeal
pouch one over here,
and then pharyngeal
membrane one in between.
what's important to
know is that these
pharyngeal apparatus
and these segments are
all associated for
with four derivative
structures so these
include bones and
cartilage arteries
cranial nerves and muscles
so where do the
pharyngeal apparatus go
in adults well when
you look at fish
and sharks for example
on the left, the
structures that
derive from pharyngeal
arches and pharyngeal
apparatus is associated
with these gills
that you see on
the sides of the head
and neck in fishes
and sharks. So they're
organs that are
involved with
respiration and feeding.
And in non-fish animals,
for example, other
mammals and birds, for
example, and lizards,
we obviously don't
have gills. but
the structures that
are derived from these
pharyngeal apparatus
are still involved
heavily with feeding
and respiration
and humans actually
have co-opted these
derivative structures
as facial muscles and
vocalizations adding
more functionality
to the structures
that come from these
pharyngeal arches.
So in previous
embryology lectures you
learned about
somites which are
packets of mesoderms
that you can see
lined up along the
anterior to posterior
axis or the body
axis of an embryo.
In the head, there are
similar structures,
but these are
called somitomeres.
And these are
units of mesoderm
in the head, but
compared to somites
that you see
them distinctly,
the distinction
is not as clear in
somitomeres. So they're
not as separated,
which you can see
of this image below.
And you can see
that the somitomeres
are responsible
for creating
mesodermal structures
in the head and
the neck. So let's
start with on the
anterior side.
So the first few
somitomeres will be used
to create extraocular
muscles. So
these are muscles
that are responsible
for eye movement.
And the more posterior
somitomeres will be
responsible for going
into the pharyngeal
arches to make mesodermal
structures, especially
the muscles that
are associated with
these pharyngeal arches.
And what's neat is
that the tongue, although
this is a structure
that exists in the
head, they are created
from mesodermal packets,
the somites, from
more posterior part of
the body. And this is
why the innervation of
the tongue, the motor
innervation, I should
say, is coming from
the most posterior
cranial nerve, which is
cranial nerve 12, or
the hypoglossal nerve.
And the arteries
are also originally
very segmented
in embryos.
So you have the
arches, and you can see
on the left in this
oblique view of an
embryo that there are
clearly defined arteries
that are based on
these pharyngeal
arches. But during
development, arches one,
two, and five mostly
disappear, and the
other arches change
shape. So the segmented
starting point
for these arteries
become kind of lost.
So you don't really
see these segmented
structures or
organizations when
you look at arteries
of a baby and
adults and humans.
So now, as with
the cranial nerves
that I went over
in my introduction
to head and neck lecture,
I recommend creating
another table
to organize the
derivatives coming
off of the
pharyngeal apparatus.
So on the leftmost
column, you can have
the arches. So arch
number one, two, three,
and then you can
put the four and six
together. And remember
that five is missing
and disappears during
development. it.
So the first arch
is also called the
mandibular arch. The
second is also called
hyoid arch. Third is
also called carotid.
Fourth and sixth are
called systemic and
pulmonary arches
respectively. And as I
mentioned before,
each of these arches
are associated with
bone and cartilage
structures, muscles,
arteries, and cranial
nerves. And after
I've gone through the
pharyngeal arch
derivatives, I'll also go
over the derivatives
coming off of the
pharyngeal pouches,
clefts, and membranes.
So just like bingo,
you get some free
space. So actually,
you can block
out two of the
spaces. So arch number
one and two do
not contribute
significantly to
any of the arteries.
so let's start with
the pharyngeal arch
one also called the
mandibular arch so the
cartilaginous and
bony derivatives of
the mandibular arch
includes the cartilaginous
precursor of the
bony mandible this
is also called meccal's
cartilage and so
the pharyngeal arch
one does not directly
create the bony
mandible but rather it
creates the cartilaginous
scaffold that will
help the bony mandible
form around it.
It also is responsible
for creating the
malleus and incus
bones. And so these
are the hammer-like
bone and the incus or
the anvil-shaped bone.
And these are tiny
bones in the middle
ear, and these help
amplify sound so
you can hear better.
And so you might be
wondering, well, this
is a mandibular arch,
so it must be related
to the lower jaw. So
why are bones that are
inside of your ear
associated with this
arch? Well, there's a
neat evolutionary story
here. And that's
because the malleus and
the incus bones used
to be jaw bones in more
primitive and ancestral
mammals. And you
see this in other non
-mammalian animals as
well. So when you take
a look at fossils of
mammal ancestors, you
see that the quadrate
and articular have
become decoupled from
the jaws and they have
slowly moved in to
the middle ear and this
transition evolutionary
transition could be
seen by looking at
a series of fossils
going from the most
primitive mammals or
mammal relative all the
way to modern mammals
which is a neat story.
And that's why the
malleus and incus are
the derivatives of
pharyngeal arch one.
So now let's talk
about the arterial
derivatives. Well,
actually, I told
you this is one of
the free spaces.
And although the
arch one contributes
to parts of the
maxillary artery and
external carotid
artery, it's too
significant to be
included in the table.
So no need to know
that for the exam.
In terms of the muscle
derivatives, you
have muscles of
mastication or also known
as jaw muscles. So
these are muscles
responsible for opening
and closing your
jaw for chewing. So
these include the
temporalis muscle,
masseter muscle, and the
pterygoids. You also
have several other
muscles. So tensor
tympani, which tenses
the tympanic membrane
or the eardrum,
tensor villi palatini,
an anterior belly of
the digastric muscle,
and then myelohyoid.
and what is the cranial
nerve associated
with these
muscles? Well, it's
cranial nerve five
or the trigeminal.
Now we'll move on to
pharyngeal arch two,
also known as
hired arch and the
cartilaginous and bony
structures that derive
from pharyngeal arch
two includes the
stapes bone, which
is the third middle
ear ossicles, and the
stylo process, which
the stylofaryngous
muscle attaches to.
And then you
have the hyoid or
parts of the hyoid,
including the
lesser horn and
the upper body.
And again, this is one of
the free spaces
for arteries.
So you don't need
to know for the
exam, but it
forms part of the
stapedio arteries
and embryos, but
that disappears
during development.
And then in
terms of muscles,
the pharyngeal arch 2
creates the
muscles of facial
expression, the
stapedius muscle that
holds on to the
stapes, and the
posterior belly
of the digastric.
And so what nerve
is responsible
for facial
expression muscles?
Well, it's the cranial
nerve 7 or the
facial nerve.
moving forward now
we're on to pharyngeal
arch 3 also known
as the carotid
arch and the cartilaginous
and bone structure
that derives from
it include the hyoid
and parts of the hyoid
which is the greater
horn and the lower
body so both the
pharyngeal arch 2 and 3
contribute to the formation
of the hyoid but
different parts of it
In terms of arteries,
it creates the
internal and external
carotid arteries.
And for muscles, it
leads to the creation of
stylopharyngous muscles.
And then the cranial
nerve that innervates
this muscle is the
glossopharyngeal nerve
or cranial nerve nine.
And it also makes
sense when you think
about what we learned
in my previous lecture,
where the carotid body
and the carotid sinus
is innervated by the
glossopharyngeal nerve.
Let's move on to
pharyngeal arch number
four also known as
systemic arch and the
cartilaginous and
bony structure here
includes the laryngeal
cartilages except for
the epiglottis and so
this is formed together
with the pharyngeal
arch number six.
In terms of arteries
it forms parts of
the aorta and the
right subclavian artery
And so what about
the left subclavian?
Well, that's formed
from what's considered
seventh arch, but it's
not discussed here
any further because
it's a very poorly
known arch in the
pharyngeal apparatus.
And in terms of
the muscles, it's
responsible for
creating the
cricothyroid, levator
veli palatini,
constrictors of the
pharynx, and the
strident muscles
of the esophagus.
And these muscles
are associated with
the vagus nerve,
which is cranial nerve
10. And pharyngeal
arch 4 actually
is responsible for
the superior laryngeal
branch or the
nerve of the vagus.
Now, the pharyngeal
arch six, also known
as pulmonary arch,
again, just like
what I've shown
you in the previous
slide, together with
pharyngeal arch four,
it's responsible
for the laryngeal
cartilages, except
for the epiglottis.
And it forms part of
the pulmonary arteries.
And in terms of
the muscles, it's
responsible for the
intrinsic laryngeal muscles.
that's actually,
it's one of its
functions is to allow
me to talk like this.
And the nerve that's
responsible for
that is the vagus
nerve, specifically
the recurrent
laryngeal nerve.
And so this is a
nice diagram that
summarizes the key
structures that are
derived from each
laryngeal arch, which
are color-coded by
the arch number.
And it doesn't include
arteries, but it
shows a lot of the
other derivatives.
So just to recap,
ARCH1 is responsible
for the meccalus
cartilage, which is that
cartilaginous precursor
to the lower jaw.
And also is responsible
for the malleus
and incus.
And those are the bony
and the cartilaginous
structures. and it's
also associated with
cranial nerve five or
trigeminal nerve that
innervates the jaw
muscles and several
other muscles as well
including the temporalis
muscle and the
masseter muscle and the
anterior body belly of
the digastric muscle.
Arch two is responsible
for the styloid
process, the stapes
which is another
ear bone and part of
the hyoid specifically
the lesser horn
and the upper body.
And it is associated
cranial nerve seven
that innervates the
muscles, the facial
expression, and
several others as well.
Arch three in blue,
the cartilage in
this arch forms
part of the hyoid,
more specifically
the greater horn of
the higher bone
in the lower body.
And the cranial nerve 9,
or the glossopharyngeal
nerve, is the one
that innervates the
stylopharyngeus muscle,
which is misspelled
on this image. It
should be STY, not STI.
And finally,
we have ARCH4.
And the cartilage
that forms from ARCH4
includes the thyroid
and cricoid cartilages,
so part of the laryngeal
cartilages, and it's
associated with the
vagus nerve, is more
specifically the
superior laryngeal nerve.
And this innervates
the pharyngeal muscles.
This is another
diagram that organizes
the structures by
anatomical systems, so by
nerves, muscles, and
cartilage in bone.
So once again,
arch one is
associated with
trigeminal nerve,
arch two with
the facial nerve,
arch three with the
glossopharyngeal
nerve, and arch
four and six
are both associated
with the vagus.
In terms of muscles,
arch one is associated
with muscles of
mastication or the
jaw opening and
closing muscles and
other muscles. Arch
two with muscles of
the facial expression
and several others.
Arch three with
the stylopharyngeus
muscle and arch four
and six with the
muscles of the larynx
and the esophagus.
In terms of
cartilaginous and bony
structures, Arch one
is associated with
mandible, malleus,
and incus. Arch
two with the hyoid,
the upper portion,
stapes, and the styler
process. Arch three
with the hyoid and
the lower portion of
the hyoid. And then
arch four and six are
associated with the
laryngeal cartilagous.
so we covered the
derivatives of the pharyngeal
arches and so now
we're ready to move
into the derivatives
of the other parts of
the pharyngeal
apparatus which includes
the cleft pouches and
the membranes and just
to help out with the
visualization recall
that the pouch is the
invagination of the
endoderm so what
that looks like three
-dimensionally so this
is a high this is a side
view of an embryo where
the pharyngeal arch
and membrane have
been removed so this
the gray is endodermal
layer and you can see
the out pocketings
of the endoderm layer
and this is what causes
the pouches to form
what makes it easier
to study is that of
the clefts and membranes
one through four
only the first one
contributes to adult
structures so you have
the pharyngeal cleft
here that becomes the
external auditory meatus.
And then the
pharyngeal membrane one
becomes a tympanic
membrane or your eardrum.
And so clefts and
membranes two, three, and
four do not contribute
to any adult structures,
which keeps it
simple. So in fact,
clefts two, three, and
four becomes invaginated
and joined together to
make a larger sinus,
the cervical sinus, which
becomes obliterated.
But when it doesn't,
it can lead to
fistula and cysts, which
we'll talk about in
our clinical call
section in a little bit.
So let's start with
pharyngeal pouch
cleft and membrane
derivatives from the
first pouch cleft
and membranes. And so
cleft one becomes
external auditory meatus,
and membrane one
becomes a tympanic
membrane or the
eardrum, which we just
covered. And then
pouch one becomes the
tympanic cavity plus
the eustachian tube
that's going to lead
into the nasopharynx.
Pharyngeal pouch
two, since we don't
have to worry about
the cleft or the
membrane, is that
pouch two becomes the
palatine tonsils. And
so tonsils are masses
of lymphoid tissue
and it traps
bacteria and viruses
entering the oral
cavity. And it also
produces antibodies to
help protect them
from the infection.
Now let's talk about
pharyngeal pouches
three and four and the
derivatives. You can
package pouch three and
four together because
their derivatives
consist of glandular
tissue that exists in
the deep neck that we
talked about in the
previous lecture. So
in the pouch three, the
cranial portion gives
rise to the inferior
parathyroid gland,
and the caudal portion
becomes the thymus.
And pouch four, the
cranial portion becomes
the superior hair
thyroid gland, and
then the caudal portion
becomes what's called
the ultimobranchial
body, which is
misspelled here. It's
missing an N in this
illustration,
ultimobranchial body. and it
gives rise to
parafollicular, also called
C-cells, and these
cells secrete calcitonin
and calcitonin acts
to reduce calcium
in the blood. So
it's another way of
controlling the level
of calcium in the body.
Now let's talk about
clinical correlates.
And so this is about
the brachial fistula
and cysts. So this
is pretty rare,
but it's good to know
what is caused by
that cervical cyst
remaining throughout
development. So normally
the cervical cyst
formed from pouches
two through four
gets obliterated, but
if they remain and
if there is an opening
into the external
environment, you
end up with openings
occurring along the
anterior margin of the
sternocleidomastoid
muscle, which you
can see on a patient
on the right here.
On the other hand, if
the cervical cyst has
an opening internally,
then it typically
follows the location
of the patine tonsils.
So you'll see an opening
inside of the mouth
at the location of
the patine tonsils. So
this is an illustration,
a drawing that
shows kind of a three
-dimensional configuration
of the pouches and
the derivatives, which
might help you
visualize and understand
the derivatives and
their relative locations,
a little bit better
than flat images.
So we have the first
pharyngeal pouch here
that becomes the
internal eustachian tube
and the middle ear or
the tympanic cavity.
You have the second
pharyngeal pouch that
becomes the site of
the palatine tonsils.
And then moving on to
the third pharyngeal
pouch, the cranial
portion becomes the
inferior parathyroid
gland, and then the
caudal portion becomes
the thymus. And then
finally, the pharyngeal
pouch forward, the
cranial portion
becomes the
superior parathyroid
gland, and the
caudal portion becomes
the ultimobranchial body.
Now that we're
done with the first
part of this
lecture, we're
ready for an example
exam question.
So a toddler has a
hearing defect. MRI
scans show that
the toddler has
developmental defects
in auditory or the
eustachian tube and
the tympanic cavity.
Which pharyngeal
apparatus component
mostly likely developed
abnormally? The
answer here is B,
pharyngeal pouch 1.
The derivatives
of pharyngeal
pouch 1 include
the tympanic
cavity and the
eustachian tube.